لقد مللنا من الحرب يا صديقي واوكرانيا ما
عادت تلبي رغباتنا اذا ما رايك بجوله على
الحلبه ماذا
تتصارع على الحلبه كياف لم تقدر على هزيمه
موسكو برغم الدعم الغربي المهول فهل تاتي
الهزيمه الروسيه على ايدي ابناء بوتين هي
حرب داخل حرب وبينما دخل عالم ذهابا
وايابا لاجل الوساطه في الحرب الاوكرانيه
يبدو انه لم يعد للصلح مكان بين القاده
الروس فقد استعرت الخلافات لتصبح الحرب
علنا بينهم فالى اين المصير عن مشاجره
ومناوشات فغنر ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
نتحدث وللقصه بقيه مقاتله امريكيه تقصف
الاف من الجنود الروس وترد منهم مئات من
القتلى والجرحى بينما الجيش الروسي يشاهد
بلا رده فعل كان هذا المشهد الذي وقع قبل
سنوات في سوريا دليلا مبكرا على العداء
بين فاغنار والجيش الروسي ومن هناك كانت
البدايه لنتاعب عقارب الزمن قليلا حيث
كانت الحادثه في فبراير عام 2018 والتي
نشرت عنها الكثير من المواقع الاخباريه
والعالميه وعلى راسها شبكه البي بي سي
وكما نتصفح امامكم المصدر فها هو يذكر
الحادثه بتفاصيلها فمن منكم سمع او راى ان
الجيش الروسي يترك افراده خلفه او انه
يكون شاهدا على مقتلهم دون ان يحرك ساكنا
انه مشهد مروع جعل يافغيني مؤسس مجموعه
فاغنر والملقب بطباخ بوتين يعيد حساباته
مره اخرى
يدخل الحلبه الاوكرانيه عندما بدات موسكو
عملياتها العسكريه ضد كيا كانت الامور
الضبابيه وبعد ان مرت ثلاث اسابيع منذ
اندلاع المعارك وفشل القوات الروسيه في
الاستيلاء على كياب وخرجت العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه عن الخطه بعد فتره وجيزه
لجا الجيش الروسي الى مجموعه فاجنار لتدخل
وحده بريكوجين القادمه من افريقيا المعركه
في مقاطعه لوهانسك بشرق اوكرانيا كون
المجموعه ذات خبره عميقه في قتال الشوارع
وحرب العصابات لتحقق فاغنر سلسله من
عمليات التقدم الكبير هذا ليس بتقرير من
عندنا بل هو حديث قائد فاغناريو جان بنفسه
لكن بريجوجان اضاف انه حتى مع قيام فاجنر
بتوسيع التجنيد بشكل كبير وخفض المعايير
فان القتال الطاحن سرعان ما استنفذ
امدادات المتطوعين فكر بريجوجان قليلا
ووجد الحل بالاستفاده من الاعداد مجهوله
للمدانين في السجون
وتجنيد المجرمين العنيفين بوعدهم بالعفو
وهو شيء لا يستطيع تحقيقه سوى بوتان اذا
بقوا على قيد الحياه لمده سته اشهر في
اوكرانيا وبالفعل حققوا التقدم الوحيد
لموسكو منذ نحو عام ونصف حيث انتصر في بعد
معركه دامت شهورا ووصفت بمفرمه اللحم لكن
قبل ان ينتصر فاجنر في باخماط هدد بريكوشن
اكثر من مره بالانسحاب وهذه المره ليس
بسبب نقص الجنود بل بسبب نقص العتاد انه
يطلب الذخيره لا غير لكن القياده في موسكو
لا تعيره اهتماما حتى زاد من حده تهديداته
لترويه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بعضا من عطشه
للذخيره بدفعه بلى بها بريكوشين ريق
مجموعته اللهثه فانتصر في باك موت بعد
اكثر من عام على المعارك هناك وسلمها فورا
للقياده الروسيه ليبحث عن جبهه جديده لكن
مهلا ماذا عن الذخيره ايها الطباخ ويال
هذا الوابل من
[موسيقى]
مضحك هذه المره حيث قال انه يجب ارسال 200
من الجنرالات الروس البالغ عددهم عشره
الاف الى اوكرانيا لماذا يا بريجوجان اجاب
لكي يجرب الركض وهم يرتدون الدروع الواقعه
على الخطوط الاماميه وكانه لم يعد للصلح
مكان فقد استعرت الخلافات بل الحرب بين
رئيس مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه
ووزاره الدفاع علنا ولاول مره بهذا الشكل
العنيف عندها ايقن ان هذه المعارك
والمناوشات الروسيه اصبحت حربا روسيه بين
القيادات بداخل الحرب الاوكرانيه اصبح
مترصدا لكل افعال وزير الدفاع الروسي وبعد
اعلان الوزاره قتل 1500 جنديا في يوم واحد
قال بريجو جان ساخرا انها مذبحه واذا
جامعنا كل الارقام التي قدمتها الوزاره
سنكون قد دمرنا كوكب الارض برمته خمس مرات
لا يكتفي بنفي التقارير والبيانات الروسيه
بل يؤكد الاخبار الاوكرانيه وها هو يؤكد
استعاده قوات كييف اجزاء من باخما واصفا
للامر بانه عار على روسيا الخلافات طفت
على السطح ويبدو ان عوده على هذا الخصام
وتطبخوا بوتين اصبح يدافع عن اوكرانيا
بنفيه لبعض العمليات الروسيه اكثر مما
يدافع الاوكران انفسهم وهنا بريجوجان يكرم
جنديا امريكيا بوضع العالم على جثته
وارساله الى امريكا وهنا يظهر طريق واحد
بعد كل هذه التوترات هو طريق الصراع
الداخلي فاين هو بوتين من كل هذا بوتين في
حيره اقرب
[موسيقى]
الذين يعيشون صراعا غير مسبوق قد ينتج عنه
شرخ في السلطات الروسيه وهذا ما يؤكده
بريكوزان بل انه يزيد على ذلك ان روسيا قد
تواجه ثوره مماثله لتلك التي حدثت عام
1917 وتخسر الصراع في اوكرانيا ما لم تكن
النخبه جاده في خوض الحرب طرح المشكله
وياتي بالحل قائلا لبوتين انه يجب استبدال
وزير الدفاع شويغو بالعقيد ميخائيل
بينما يجب استبدال رئيس الاركان العامه
فاليري
جيراسيموفوكين الملقب بالجنرال هارماجيدا
وختم حديثه بقوله انا احب وطني الام انا
يجب الحكم على شويغو وسنواصل القتال واضاف
واصفا كبار رجال الجيش في بوتين بانهم
وسامحون على اللفظ فقد قال انهم
وسيلقون مصيرهم اعداء بريغوجين لا يردون
على تصريحات لكنهم لا يدعمونه بالاسلحه
والذخيره ايضا ليوجه هو وقواته مصيرهم على
ارض المعارك اما بوتين فهو في حيره من
امره ان يمضي بنصائح طباخه المقرب ام
يستمع لوزير دفاعه ورئيس اركانه وهنا لم
تنتهي الحكايه وما دام بريكوشنحي فلن
تتوقف انتقاداته اللاذعه بوتين لا يجهل كل
ما يحدث لكنه يحيى تماما ان الجيش خلال
اوقات الحرب يميل الى كسب مزيد من السلطه
داخل الدوله ويعلم انه كلما استمرت الحرب
تزايدت هذه السلطه وزادت صعوبه ممارسه
سيطرته عليه لذا فهو يكبح جيم جينيرالته
بترك الطباخه بريغوشان يتحرك كما يحلو له
ويقول ما يريد وطالما ان ذلك يجعل الامور
تظل محكمه في يد بوتين فلا غير من مناوشات
بعض القاده الزعيم الروسي لن يفرط بمجموعه
فاغنر التي
لروسيا ليس في اوكرانيا فقط بل في العالم
الخارجي فقد اسست فاجنر لروسيا امبراطوريه
في افريقيا بارخص التكاليف وهناك سبب اخر
لصمت بوتين انما تصريحاته وهذا السبب قاله
يفجن حديثا بان قواتنا لا تكفي للاطاحه
ببوتان والرئيس الروسي يعي ذلك جيدا في
روسيا يبدو ان كل شيء متوقف على سير
المعارك على الاراضي الاوكرانيه فالحصار
المعارك وتمددها الشيء وخذلان القياده
الروسيه لمجموعه فاجنر شيء اخر لكن
التراجع الروسي في اوكرانيا قد لا ياتي
بفعل القوات الاوكرانيه بل بسبب مناوشات
القاده الروس فهل يسمح بوتين بذلك
[موسيقى]